[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat pour lutter contre
la pauvreté à l'école le gouvernement
vient de lancer plusieurs dispositifs la
cantine à 1 euro et des petits déjeuners
gratuits
l'académie de versailles fait d'ailleurs
partie des huit académies test ce sont
les écoles situées dans les réseaux
d'éducation prioritaires qui seront
concernés dans un premier temps ces
mesures sont-elles facilement applicable
c'est le thème tu et des parcs du jour
autour de cette table à jacquet et
jeanne-marie bonsoir à vous êtes
adjointe au maire de trappes délégué à
l'éducation et à la petite enfance
en face de vous manuel afonso cancel
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes président de
la pub de montigny le bretonneux vous
êtes également à secrétaire de
l'association départementale la pub je
rappel c'est la fédération un des
parents d'élèves de l'enseignement
public et merci à toutes les deux dettes
présentes ce soir alors il ya six mois
le gouvernement présentait donc fonds
plan de lutte contre la pauvreté
certaines mesures sont sur le point
d'être lancé à commencer par des petits
déjeuners gratuits c'est dans les écoles
situées en réseau en réseau d'éducation
prioritaire
il faut savoir que selon un sondage du
credoc le centre de recherche pour
l'étude et l'observation des conditions
de vie
25% des 3 11 ans ne prennent pas de
petit déjeuner tous les matins un manuel
afonso cancer que pensez vous tout
d'abord cette première mesure c'est
petit déjeuner gratuit à l'école alors
ce que j'en pense moi en tant que
représentante de parents d'élèves de
l'apeps et que je dois rappeler un des
principes fondamentaux de notre
association de parents d'élèves qui est
la primauté éducatif du pas rond dans la
vie de l'enfant
ce que je pense de la mise en place de
ceux de ce dispositif c'est que bien sûr
il ya des familles qui pour des raisons
financières peuvent se retrouver en
difficulté pour pour nourrir leurs
enfants cependant il ne faut pas oublier
le rôle principal du parent qui est
celui d' éduquer son enfant de
l'accompagner et l'éducation passe
également par la réponse à ses besoins
fondamentaux qui sont l'hygiène et
l'alimentation ferez pas l'école
finalement deux foyers de jouer ce rôle
je pense que l'école peut avoir un rôle
de formation d'information auprès des
familles mais est ce que c'est vraiment
son rôle de prendre à sa charge le côté
alimentaire de l'éducation de l'enfant
j'émets des doutes
alors jésus marie dans ce même sondage
du credoc on apprend qu'en moyenne 3 4
élèves par classe arrive le ventre vide
à l'école en particulier en rep et en
rêve plus alors est ce que c'est une
situation que l'on rencontre dans les
écoles la trappe
on rencontre on a déjà rencontré on a
déjà fait des petits déjeuners en 2007
jusqu'à 2009 je crois et ça a été
supprimée la demande de l'éducation
nationale parce que il y avait aussi à
l'époque un plan de lutte contre
l'obésité
voilà aujourd'hui on y revient j'ai pas
sur les mois ou obèses qui nous barre
d'abord qu'est ce qu'on appelle un petit
déjeuner d'abord si tous déjà s'entendre
là-dessus pour certains c'est juste un
liquide le matin à avaler pour d'autres
on se met à table à moi j'en connais qui
prennent la poêle et y cuisiner qui se
met à table c'est quoi un petit déjeuner
sac à sa version des choses
après c'est sûr que c'est aux parents de
faire dégeler les enfants les
allocations familiales normalement
doivent ses environs ce genre de choses
mais on s'aperçoit quand même que on l'a
vu avec le début des gilets jaunes
il ya des parents qui à 1100 euros je
suis désolé mais ils peuvent parents ne
peuvent pas moi j'ai connu à des
situations dramatiques sur la ville des
gens des enfants qui n'allait pas la
cantine le midi et qui attendait que les
dames de service je peux vous dire que
ça m'est toujours resté en travers de
l'estomac des cas tandis que les dames
de service à y jeter le non consommés
dans les poubelles pour eux allaient
prendre leur déjeuner quand on a connu
ça je vous assure qu'on a une autre
vision de la société et que on s'en
remet les pieds sur terre
alors on parlera justement des cantines
ce que c'est un détail c'est justement
de payer leur monde va payer non plus le
petit déjeuner alors c'est encore flou
évidemment ce dispositif petit déjeuner
à l'école au début du mois une école d
des mureaux qui a expérimenté cette
opération à ce que ça va être le cas à
attraper ce que vous savez sinon on va y
travailler on verra ça à la rentrée de
septembre on va y travailler avec
l'inspectrice de l'éducation nationale
on va regarder quelles sont les
modalités est-ce que gas un petit
déjeuner tripous pas est-ce que c'est
sur la base du volontariat
est-ce que ça se passe sur le temps
scolaire ou périscolaire moi j'en sais
rien aujourd'hui n'en sais rien je sais
que j'ai une obligation mais il ne s'est
pas le contenu de l'obligation si l'on
peut servir en qui désole et donc qui
désole jean rapenne c'est quoi est ce
que vous savez si ça va être appliquée
avant de signer le bretonneux
ce type d'opération de petit déjeuner
gratuit
alors aujourd'hui nous n'avons aucune
visibilité non plus sur nos amis bretons
ne soyons bien d'accord si loi il y a
techniquement la ville s'y pliera mais
je ne peux pas me prononcer pour pour
mes élus alors autres dispositifs on
dise annoncé par le gouvernement dans le
cadre de ce plan de lutte contre la
pauvreté est la cantine à 1 euro pour
les parents les communes qui s'engagent
d'ailleurs recevront une aide de l'état
de 2 euros par repas on en parle dans
quelques instants
mais que pense tout d'abord les
yvelinois de cette mesure et calypso
vanier leur a posé la question
ça permettra sans doute à des familles
n'ont pas les moyens de mettre leurs
enfants à la cantine de pouvoir le faire
et de le faire aussi souvent que besoin
il faut que les enfants puissent les
jeunes puissent bénéficier bénéficier de
repas gratuits
ou très peu onéreux je trouve que c'est
une bonne c'est une bonne décision
la cantine c'est ça permet aussi aux
déjeuners d'avoir un repas équilibré au
moins les enfants auront un repas
équilibré
on espère équilibrer même pas rejoué ce
sera aussi intéressant pour les familles
qui qui habite dans une ville qui
laissent leurs enfants scolarisés dans
notre notre ville et qu' ils payent la
cantine
plein tarif donc ça peut être aussi
intéressant c'est la ville
il s'engage dans ce principe né lors
jeanny marc il attrape c'est une cuisine
centrale à combien reviennent les repas
le repas est à moins de trois euros
contenu de l'assiette moins de 3 euros
malgré la qualité que tout le monde
connaît maintenant puisque c'est paru
dans la face c'est tout c'était une
volonté municipale
justement parce qu'on a on a ces
familles très défavorisées pour
certaines pas tout vous inquiétez pas il
ya d'excellents revenus sur la ville moi
j'en connais quelques-uns
ils peuvent payer la cantine au tarif où
il le paye aujourd'hui
mais en même temps il ya des enfants
pour lesquels effectivement la dame a
raison ce n'est que le repas de la
journée
donc autant leur offrir une qualité et
un vrai repas le la qualité que nous
menons temps bio pente circuits courts
et puis allez choisir sa bête sur pied
comme on peut maintenant et je vais être
pareil pour pour l'agneau est ce que
vous vous associez déjà à des
agriculteurs de la région
oui j'ai toujours été une volonté que
j'ai imposé avec bleu blanc coeur ont
déjà c'est une qualité reconnue et quand
on nous a proposé des circuits courts
parce que il ya aussi un problème d'
écologie dont il faut tenir compte des
agriculteurs locaux qui ont du bétail et
on a le cahier des charges de la
nourriture des des animaux on sait qui a
la qualité pour quoi ne pas l'offrir
alors vous dites 3 euros donc leur part
aurait moins de 3 euros le contenu de
l'assiette d'accord et les parents paye
combien être alors les parents payent
proportionnellement leurs ressources ça
s'étale de combien il ya c'est ça du
banc ça démarre à 15 centimes pour le
matériel 45 centimes pour l'élémentaire
parce que le drama j'ai un petit peu
plus fort
et puis ça peut aller jusqu'à 5 6 euros
selon les ressources donc finalement
vous cette cantine donc à 1 euro en fait
je suis pas intéressé d'abord super g -
plus de dix mille habitants
mais en même temps je sais pas
intéressés parce que si je devais faire
le repas un euro mais j'ai des tas de
gens qui disparaîtraient de la cantine
et de calais pourcentage des élèves qui
mangent à la super g par le pourcentage
ce soir mais il ya un bon nombre d un
abandon à peu près de mille repas je
crois par jour ou quelque chose comme ça
donc c'est énorme c'est la moitié de
scolarité à un meeting à montigny le
bretonneux quelle est la situation
justement au niveau du coude et des
repas il ya
une échelle écouter sur
montigny-le-bretonneux le coup le coût
est relativement bien maîtrisé parce que
c'est pareil au fonctionne sur un
système de quotient familial en va d'une
échelle de quatre euros 22 à 1 euro 24
par repas on a également un système de
réservation qui est vraiment très bien
pensé qui permet d'annuler jusqu'à 24
heures avant avant la journée de repas
donc ça permet également d'ajuster par
rapport à son budget avec beaucoup de
flexibilité
après on a quand même une sacrée volonté
de la delà de l'équipe municipale de
faire participer les parents dans les
voiles à se dire vous participez en fait
aller vers la ration d'aller enfin nous
sommes nous sommes nous pète mais
également les autres fédérations de
parents d'élèves présente sur la ville
c'est plus nappes et les parents c'est
la grande nouveauté de cette année un
siège réservé aux aux associations de
parents d'élèves indépendante qui on
travaille ensemble en concertation
accompagné par le prestataire de
restauration scolaire le service de la
vie scolaire de la mairie ainsi que
l'élu madame blanc qui fait qui a
vraiment à coeur d'être présente à
chacune de ces commissions pour
travailler ensemble sur une trame de
menus à on travaille le deuxième très le
troisième trimestre au deuxième
trimestre et ses voisins de manière à
pouvoir proposer un choix important
équilibré avec toujours la vie des
parents et surtout mettre en place
d'autres mesures telles que 25 % de bio
à la cantine mise en place de circuits
courts une cuisine centrale proche et
surtout du local on essaie de faire au
maximum
elle fait que ça revienne à 1 euro pour
les parents est ce que vous ne pensez
pas du coup qui aurait encore plus
d'enfants qui mangera
ben j'ai surtout peur c'est qu'on
finissent par rogner sur d'autres
prestations
la qualité d'animation détente de temps
périscolaire le tout ça c'est un coup
c'est inclus dans le prix qu'on propose
aux familles mais si on finit par
descendre un prix beaucoup plus bas
j'ai peur que la com on dire la qualité
d'une autre d'une autre partie finissent
par être sacrifié cette émission touche
bientôt à sa fin on va commencer à
conclure vous allez avoir une minute
chacune pour pour conclure par rapport
donc à ces mesures du gouvernement petit
déjeuner gratuit
cantine à 1 euro est ce que selon vous
c'est ce serait efficace pour lutter
contre la pauvreté
je ne bois pas je ne crois pas parce que
c'est un problème de ressources des
familles tant qu'on n'augmentera pas les
ressources des familles au niveau du
coût de la vie de ce qu'est une famille
de ba de deux enfants et un couple on
n'y arrivera pas on n'y arrivera pas
c'est pas la collectivité qui est la
collectivité dès que les collectivités
prennent beaucoup penchard j'en entends
suffisamment dur que les collectivités
dépensent trop votre qu'elle fasse des
économies par des économies on est
d'abord peut-être vous enlever quelques
charges et non loulé sur moi si je
prends l'argent dans la poche du voisin
forcément du fait des économies
voilà
n'entendant tant qu'on n'aura pas trouvé
la solution au problème des ressources
des familles des revenus des familles du
salaire on n'aura pas le on aura pas la
solution et c'est même pas j'ai même pas
envie de dire c'est c'est l'état c'est
aussi des entreprises dans les salaires
sont les entreprises voilà moi je
rejoins je rejoins madame marie sur sur
son avis concernant les ressources des
familles comme je les dis au démarrage
pour nous à la peuplent le plus
important c'est la primauté éducatif du
parent si le parent doit faire son
travail d'éducateur il faut qu'il ait
les moyens de le faire et les moyens on
va pas se mentir c'est l'argent qu'on a
dans le porte monnaie disponible en
début de mois actuellement je ne veux
pas rentrer en politique vis-à-vis de
vis-à-vis des mouvements sociaux qui a
actuellement mais je pense que la france
elle-même et keita c'est en train de
dire le mal être quelle vie à ce sujet
est-ce que la cantine à 1 euro et le
petit déjeuner offert sont une solution
seul l'avenir nous le dira la racing
solution c'est comment dire un pansement
sur une jambe de bois
bon mes enfants ont le ventre plein
c'est déjà ça les enfants faire au moins
ça fait au moins ça pour autant
j'adorais son patient souffre
nous sommes aux côtés de la famille et
c'est ça le drame le plus important
c'est toujours de penser par et pour nos
enfants leur facilité et le quotidien et
le bien-être et surtout l'accessibilité
à l'éducation ça passe par
l'alimentation
ça passe par son bien-être au quotidien
et donc l'action des équipes au
périscolaire et là vous pouvez être sûr
que vous trouverez toujours des équipes
de parents derrière pour soutenir les
collectivités dans leurs actions
merci à ce théâtre est d'avoir été à
présent que ce soir voilà c'est la fin
de cette émission
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve à mercredi prochain
[Musique]